[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de votre
journal local nous sommes le lundi 20
septembre voici les titres
le directeur académique des yvelines
s'est rendu ce jeudi à l'école thomas
pesquet de villepreux le but de la
visite assister aux évaluations
nationales des élèves de cp un
diagnostic qui permet d'établir les
forces et les fragilités des enfants
pour mieux les accompagner elle est
aveugle dans les yvelines la pratique du
vélo taf a augmenté depuis le
déconfinement le procédé consiste à
réaliser son trajet domicile travail à
vélo témoignage d'un vélo à feurs dans
cette édition et puis les journées du
patrimoine se sont déroulées samedi et
dimanche retour sur ce week-end culturel
nous recevrons la directrice du château
de monte-cristo et l'administratrice du
domaine nationale de rambouillet pour
dresser le bilan de ces deux jours
[Musique]
trois ans en 2024 paris accueillera la
33e olympiade de l'ère moderne une
grande fête qui démarre déjà avec de
nombreux événements jusqu'à l'échéance
mondiale samedi à 18 septembre le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueillez le passage des deux
impôts olympique l'occasion pour le
public de rencontrer les athlètes
tricolores un reportage de grégory
canale et mélanie poquet c'est génial de
dire qu'on est gagnants sera en train de
représenter les hauts salaires fixes et
c'est important que ce seront bien
gardées un point on est impatient on
attend et on sera derrière l'équipe de
prost la photo dans paris 2024 ce n'est
que dans trois ans et pourtant
l'engouement est déjà présent
athlètes et nous ont déambulé sur la
piste du vélodrome nationale dans leurs
mains les drapeaux des comités
olympiques paralympiques et de paris
2024 qui faisait étape à montigny le
bretonneux ce 18 septembre le compte à
rebours des jeux en france a bien
démarré se veut vraiment dire que ça y
est on y est on est pays on est le pays
de l'olympisme réel pays du
paralympiques mme on a attendu longtemps
on a même attendu un an de plus à cause
de la qu'ovide des jeux qui se
dérouleront également sur le territoire
saint quentinois vélodrome mais aussi
golf national à guyancourt et la colline
à elancourt comme sites olympiques
l'agglomération se prépare
qu'est ce que t'es beau que de le
réveiller l'envi de donner envie à
quelqu'un de se dépasser c'est le top
c'est une fois en plus tous les siècles
on peut l'avoir en est très fier surya
pour saint quentin
dit être associés aussi directement
cette cérémonie des drapeaux étaient le
moment aussi de croiser les sportifs qui
rêvent de paris 2024 l'apparat
triathlète cécile sabouraud les pistards
quentin lafargue quentin caleyron timmy
gillion et florian rainbow tout
fraîchement médaillé de bronze en
vitesse par équipes c'était l'occasion
pour lui de fêter avec le public présent
sur tokyo on n'avait pas forcément le
public bah ça montre qu'on est soutenu
et c'est je vous ai jamais dire depuis
le retour en france c'est là qu'on se
rend compte vraiment ce que sont les
jeux olympiques et on se rend compte que
c'est quelque chose qui touche tout le
monde qui touche vraiment tout pays donc
vraiment content vraiment fier pouvoir
partager tout ça les drapeaux olympique
doivent circuler dans une trentaine de
villes en france prochaine étape dans
les yvelines le 16 octobre sur la
colline d'elancourt
depuis cinq ans septembre les élèves de
cp sont évalués en français et en
mathématiques des tests nationaux qui
permettent de déterminer les points
forts et les fragilités et des élèves
l'exemple avec l'école élémentaire
thomas pesquet de villepreux le
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et célia gars de son goût
dans cette classe de cp à l'école
élémentaire thomas pesquet de villepreux
tous les élèves participent aux
évaluations nationales des cp instauré
depuis cinq ans ce sont des évaluations
diagnostiques qui ont pour but de voir
des forces et fragilité des enfants de
façon individuelle et collective moi je
trouve que ces évaluations sont plus que
nécessaires aujourd'hui on peut mettre
un doigt sur les difficultés ou les
réussites parce que ces évaluations
canton à 100% de réussite partout c'est
aussi témoignage de quelque chose de
leurs compétences l'inspecteur
d'académie des yvelines et l'inspectrice
de la circonscription ont fait à cette
occasion le déplacement objectif voir
comment se passent les évaluations pour
les élèves mais aussi pour les
professeurs une réunion avait lieu juste
avant avec les professeurs pour faire un
point et un bilan sur ces dévaluations
les outils se sont affinés se sont
stabilisés et désormais c'est devenu
vraiment quelque chose de naturel c'est
à dire que les enseignants sont
complètement confiant les familles
savent qu'on n'est pas là pour juger
mais qu'on est là pour aider et donc le
rendez-vous individuels aussi sert aux
professeurs d'appui pour échanger avec
la famille dans les yvelines ce sont
près de 18000 élèves de cp qui vont
passer ces tests jusqu'au 23 septembre
des séances d'apprentissage de la
lecture on était aussi observé sur le
département depuis deux ans une nouvelle
modalité de formation s'est mise en
place appelez le plan lecture les
enseignants de villepreux l'année
dernière ont été formés en constellation
c'est à dire en groupe d'enseignante et
elles ont travaillé ensemble sur de
nouvelles modalités d'apprentissage de
la lecture alors elles ne sont pas
partis de rien elles n'ont pas changé
complètement ce qu'elle faisait mais
elles ont enrichi leurs pratiques dans
l'académie de versailles 80% des élèves
de cp sont entrés de manière
satisfaisante dans la lecture
dimanche les élus de onze communes de la
vallée de chevreuse se sont mobilisés à
cerner la ville près de 80 personnes
dont des riverains étaient présentes
pour lutter contre les nuisances sonores
des motos un phénomène étudié ces
dernières années d'après les élus
concernés près de 500 motos en deux
heures sont de passage à dampierre sur
les week-ends de printemps ou d'été 60%
des véhicules sont en excès de vitesse
l'interview téléphonique de la mère
claire gérer la mère de cerner la ville
a retrouvé sur nos réseaux
contraction entre vélo et taf le vélo tu
as fait une pratique qui consiste à
faire son trajet domicile travail en
vélo une habitude en plein essor dans
les yvelines depuis le déconfinement une
augmentation enregistrée grâce à
plusieurs capteurs installés dans le
département celui de croissy sur seine
par exemple aurait enregistré + 2 235
mille passages en 2020 contre 165 milles
en 2019 un boom qui s'expliquait
notamment par le développement est des
vélos à assistance électrique dans le
cadre de la semaine de la mobilité à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines céline charlas
a rencontré un vélo tu as peur regarder
il est 8h et au lieu de monter dans sa
voiture comme la plupart des français
christian enfourche son vélo tous les
matins il dépose sa fille à l'école et
se rend au travail en vélo une pratique
qui ne changerait pour rien au monde ça
fait un an que je suis sur ce poste ça
fait un an que je viens toujours à vélo
alors que j'ai un scooter un bus direct
voiture et mais franchement une fois
qu'on a pris le couvent il faut s'y
mettre et après c'est presque une drogue
mais quand on vient pas de 4,5 jours à
vélo ben ça manque on traverse et comme
des beaux endroits on a quand même une
région qui est assez entre bois d'arcy
et ici c'est quand même assez rebours et
il ya pas mal de pistes cyclables c'est
tranquille s'est détendu embouteillages
pollution carburant ou encore
stationnement de plus en plus de
personnes délaissent les moyens de
transport habituel pour se mettre au
vélo les avantages sont nombreux en fait
un peu d'exercice c'est pas mal on
s'aère un peu l'esprit et le corps
et puis
et puis je dirais en terme de
pas d'économies de transport quoi pas de
pas de panne navigo pour le transport
pas de parking pas de klaxons pas de
bouchon à l'arrivée christian dépose son
vélo dans la ville aux stations de saint
quentin en yvelines créé il ya quatre
ans par l'agglomération elle offre pour
30 euros par an des multiples services à
ceux qui comme christian ont fait le
choix de se déplacer à vélo tous les
jours le premier service dont passer la
consigne donc monsieur bénéficie pour
pouvoir garer son vélo en toute sécurité
le deuxième service ça va être donc un
la location de vélos trois types de
vélos vélos standard vélos à assistance
électrique vélo clients tout ça dans le
but effectivement de promouvoir en fait
là les trajets domicile travail et
troisième pied donc de la vélostation de
l'atelier de réparation alors vélo
transports en commun en voiture il n'ya
plus à hésiter pour ceux qui seraient
convaincus la vélostation propos
jusqu'au 22 septembre encore un vélo à
40 euros pour un an
et dans le même thème dans le cadre de
la semaine de la mobilité
l'agglomération est de saint quentin en
yvelines organise la première édition du
challenge vélo interentreprises un
événement en partenariat avec you win
bike c'est une application mobile qui
permet d'attester de son déplacement en
vélo pour se rendre au travail et du
nombre aussi de kilomètres parcourus le
but encourager la pratique du vélo mais
aussi expérimenter cette nouvelle
application
lauréate d'un appel à projet d'île de
france mobilité l'événement a débuté ce
jeudi 16 septembre il se poursuivra
jusqu'au 15 octobre pour déterminer le
meilleur cycliste le meilleur rouleur ou
encore la meilleure entreprise cyclistes
[Musique]
et
ce week-end se déroulait la 38e édition
des journées du patrimoine
l'occasion pour les e-livres yvelinois
de découvrir des facettes cachées des
lieux emblématiques qui nous entoure
c'est le cas par exemple au musée
archéologique de saint germain en laye
un atelier proposé de découvrir les
moyens de protéger sécuriser et évaluer
les oeuvres d'art un reportage de
nicolas d'andré antoine durand est à
retrouver en intégralité sur nos réseaux
les gens d'une patrie moi donc je le
disais sont déroulées samedi 18 et
dimanche 19 septembre terme de cette 38e
édition patrimoine pour tous et
patrimoine ferroviaire au programme de
ce week end culturel spectacles
expositions ou encore des visites
étaient organisées le bilan de cet
événement avec nos invités du jour
frédéric lui roll directrice du château
de monte cristo située à port marly est
avec nous et isabelle de gourkuff
administratrice du domaine nationale de
rambouillet bonsoir à toutes les deux
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation alors
frédéric lureau la la demeure était
ouverte donc d'alexandre dumas et être
ouvertes au public qu'est ce qui était
proposé déjà aux visiteurs
alors nous les visiteurs pourraient
ambühl et dans le parc dans lequel nous
avions toujours notre exposition d'art
contemporain qui était présentée une
exposition de sculptures de pierre
treilhes à les sculptures jalonnent le
parquet il y en a également au deuxième
étage du château le visiteur pouvait
également bien sûr visiter la demeure
d'alexandre dumas dans son intégralité
nous avions l'intervention d'une
comédienne le dimanche est un comédien
le samedi ces derniers faisaient des
interventions ponctuelles auprès des
visiteurs et endossé les rôles soient de
personnages issus de l'imagination
d'alexandre dumas soit deux personnages
qui ont réellement connu alexandre dumas
puis il y avait aussi quelques
opérations de médiation auprès du auprès
du public et pour vous et isabelle de
gourkuff quel était le programme de ces
journées au château de rambouillet en
tout cas au domaine très riche qui était
proposé à nos visiteurs d'avoir le
château était entièrement gratuits comme
le sont les monuments nationaux et les
visiteurs ont été nombreux pour re
découvrir le château de manière un petit
peu original parce que le parcours
avaient complètement été modifié et le
rêve de tout visiteur qui est de gravir
l'escalier de la tour médiévale de la
tour françois 1er et est récompensé et
mais avec une surprise en haut de
l'escalier c'est que on y trouve la
chaîne l'appartement des chefs d'état
étrangers c'est à dire que les
appartements qui ont été aménagés dans
le cadre du rambouillet résidence
présidentielle qui a accueilli de
nombreux chefs d'état et donc c'était
très intéressant de partir finalement de
du moyen-âge pour aller jusqu à
l'histoire très récente du château et
attend un aménagement des années 50 de
jean-patrick patrimoniale mans très
intéressant et ensuite descendre et
continuer à visiter le château les
grands appartements que les visiteurs
plus nombreux déjà à connaître et
ensuite la déambulation
continuer à la laiterie la haine marient
entre eux d'être compact et la chaumière
aux coquillages ce sont de petites
perben qui joyau xviiie siècle qui se
niche dans le parc et l'originalité
aussi de la programmation cette année
était de présenter une exposition de
photographies en partenariat avec festif
au dos
mais l'originalité c'est que ce sont
deux jardiniers du château de jardiniers
extraordinaire qui connaissent
tous les détours les détours du jardin
et leurs habitants et et qui sont des
passionnés de photo et qui depuis trente
ans photographie traque la faune du parc
que les videmment avant les promeneurs
sont nombreux à venir régulièrement dans
jara n'imagine pas qu'il ya toute cette
population tous ces oiseaux
extraordinaire le chevreuil etc et donc
ils ont été pris sur le vif avaient très
très belle exposition très poétique
l'exposition d'ailleurs de ces
passionnés et donc là on disait c'est la
38e édition comment on fait en fait pour
se renouveler chaque année
on se renouvelle une certaine manière ce
que j'attends ce qu'il est et on ne
changera pas mais ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est ouvrir des espaces cachés de
me parler de théâtre françois 1er
personne ne l'avait jamais vu et puis
des petits plus comme l'exposition de
photos par exemple
frédéric lureau lequel retour avez-vous
du public à cette année
c'est très positif à chaque fois les le
public est toujours très heureux de
venir découvrir ce lieu ils sont très
surpris de voir que ce petit écrin de
verdure et préservé parce que nous
sommes vraiment dans un noyau assez
dense de circulation et d'urbanisation
or montecristo est vraiment niché dans
un écrin de verdure et l' architecture
des deux bâtiments est tellement
étonnante tellement insolite que c'est
ce qui ressort d'une visiteurs qui est
vraiment ravi d'avoir le plaisir d'une
telle découverte un bilan positif donc
c'était pareil à avant bouyer oui et non
beaucoup de visiteurs a raconté
2700 de 1700 visiteurs contre 237
l'année dernière ok c'est beaucoup alors
ça pas encore la fréquentation de 2019
qui était une année de très bonne
fréquentation n'allez normal on peut
dire mais on sent qu'il ya une confiance
en tout cas aujourd'hui à se rendre
patrimoniaux évidemment à vous présenter
son passage du ter etc toutes les
consignes il gestes barrières sont bien
appliqués mais les visiteurs peuvent
venir en toute sécurité et ça je pense
que les manceaux c'est important ça
s'est ressenti justement que c'est
encore une année un peu particulière
cette année
sanitaires
willy juan monde et c'est certain que le
col pas sanitaire peut-être mieux de sa
personne mais les mets re 1700 personnes
c'est quand même beaucoup pour un site
comme le nôtre devrait cris cayrol petit
c'est la même chose de son côté donc on
est franchement plutôt confiant d'un
très confiant dans le fait que nous
allons progressivement retrouver les
plantations normale dans l'est dans les
mois qui vont venir est justement là on
en parle et frédéric l'hérault l'on
disait il y avait du monde finalement ce
week-end le public a finalement été
présent c'était important pour lui de se
retrouver aujourd'hui ah oui oui cette
planète on sent qu'il ya un désir de
sortie un désir de découverte un désir
de partage c'est absolument évident
qu'on a reçues 00h tu mens personnes en
deux jours ce qui est beaucoup c'est
plus que l'an dernier hors déjà l'an
dernier nous avions bien entendu
ressenti les mêmes les mêmes choses les
visiteurs sont vraiment avides de
pouvoir
profiter de leur liberté
même si bien entendu le pass sanitaire
est exigée à l'entrée mais on a
absolument pas de
de commentaires négatifs à ce niveau là
enfin à ces deux jours là
est ce qu'on a mis la barre plus haut du
fait justement de cette crise sanitaire
ne pas pouvoir se retrouver pendant un
an finalement les établissements
culturels étaient fermés est ce qu'on a
mis la barre plus haut à ce niveau là
pour ces journées
nous on a essayé d'être dans la
continuité de ce qu'on propose
habituellement nous avions prévu cette
exposition d'art contemporain on a
réussi à la mettre en place et on en est
vraiment ravi on a été très content
pouvoir la partager avec le public
nombreux des journées du patrimoine
maintenant cette exposition se termine à
la fin la semaine elle était déjà
présent tout l'été
non nous on a continué vraiment notre
agenda culturel n'a pas été modifié
mais on est on est heureux de voir que
le public est là on répond présent et du
côté de rambouillet du coup lors d'une
technique ce qui était important pour
nous cette année c'est de marquer le pas
d'une la future du futur du château qui
est que la présence la république
pressant maquereau a décidé que
rambouillet ne serait plus utilisé en
tant que résidence ni pour défaire
protocolaire d'ailleurs ce qui veut dire
que dans les prochaines années nous
allons pouvoir ouvrir de nouveaux
espaces et conduire un projet culturel
est vraiment faire visiter le château de
fond en comble il ya encore beaucoup de
personnes qui me disent ah bon parce que
rambouillet on peut y rentrer et on ice
qui fermait la présidence est ternie oui
le château de rambouillet est ouvert
aujourd'hui tout n'est pas encore ouvert
sécurité d'aménagement etc ça va prendre
un peu de temps mais on peut tous les
jours sauf le mardi visité le château et
ses deux petits bijoux qui sont recensés
fabrique dans les jardins et qui sont
désormais tous les jours ouverte et
justement brièvement est-ce qu'on peut
rappeler peut-être les prochains
événements à venir pour l'une et l'autre
alors en ce qui concerne les cristaux
les prochains les prochains événements
sont la semaine prochaine on reçoit
opération d'emine opérations du
département des yvelines
et puis la semaine suivante nous
organisons notre 21e salon du livre
jeunesse dans le parc du château une
opération qui a toujours du succès
j'espère que cette année sera toujours
dans le même esprit
d pour le chaque tour nous avons
l'exposition fantaisie pour un palais
le château rêvez vous est offert x une
promenade dans le noir avec des
éclairages qui va être très très très
très joli très séduisant à partir du 10
novembre
la nouveauté au siceco château sera
ouvert le 1er et le 11 novembre temps
que l'exposition qui se prolongera
jusqu'en mars avec des épisodes pour les
enfants et les familles pendant les
vacances
on des histoires des vacanciers et
suivent ensuite au printemps où
l'attend un conte spectacle secret
défense sur le général de gaulle qui
accueille azénor heures au château de
rambouillet eh bien écoutez c'est noté
dans les deux cas merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous je le remercie frédéric
lui rôle du coup directrice du château
de monte-cristo et isabelle de gourkuff
administratrice du domaine nationale de
rambouillet d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
des vidéos à gogo dans la salle des
fêtes du perray-en-yvelines ce samedi 18
septembre un événement organisé par la
commune sur une idée du conseil
municipal des jeunes le principe du père
et game show rétro gaming simulation de
conduite casque en réalité virtuelle ou
encore just dance les visiteurs avaient
le choix entre différents types de
consoles des tournois ont été organisés
entre fifa mario kart ou encore super
smash et des animations accompagné à 2
prévention sur les jeux vidéos on écoute
tout de suite le maire du
perray-en-yvelines geoffrey dax de
keating au micro de mélanie poké avec
nicolas landry vous avez plein de choses
dans les jeux vidéo c'est à la fois des
le travail sur la réflexion le travail
sur la mémoire sur la stratégie donc il
ya beaucoup de bière fait aux jeux vidéo
évidemment en
petites doses mais c'est pour ça que les
jeunes ont voulu lancer ce projet et
puis pour toucher massivement l'ensemble
des jeunes de la commune mais pas que
parce que aussi les familles c'est assez
familial
sachez qu'une nouvelle édition est déjà
prévue pour l'année prochaine et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi dans un instant vous
retrouverez michael elby d'euros pour le
7-8 sport très bonne soirée à tous sur
télé 78
[Musique]